welcome back uh families of foreign
sling for slain Oklahoma men follow
wrongful death lawsuit weeks after their
dismembered bodies were found in a river
near where they were last seen Billy
chaston Mark chaston and Alex Stevens
and Mike Sparks were last seen riding
bikes on October 9th their disappearance
prompted a week-long surge until their
dismembered bodies were found in a river
nearly one week later investigators used
cell phone data from a victim's wife to
track the group back to several salvage
yards belonging to 76 year old Joe
Kennedy at first officials say Kennedy
was cooperative but after he was named a
person of interest he disappeared he was
later arrested in Daytona Beach Florida
in a stolen vehicle though no criminal
charges have been filed against Kennedy
in the murders family members of three
of the four victims filed suit against
Kennedy and his wife alleging Joseph
knowingly caused the man's death the
suit calls for a 75 thousand dollars in
Damages saying it temporary injunction
should be held on both Joseph and Sandra
so they couldn't liquidate their assets
Terry is filing a civil suit this early
in a criminal investigation somewhat
premature what if he isn't even charged
with any crimes
well you know I think it's a bit early
Brian but I don't think it's premature I
think it was a very strategic move on
the part of the families to try to
freeze those assets after all he did try
to flee and frankly a criminal
conviction is helpful but it's not
necessary under Oklahoma law all you
have to do to bring a wrongful death
action is to have negligence on the part
of the person who brought that wrongful
act or medical malpractice or an
intentional act and that would include a
criminal act so I think smart move on
the part of the families Gene there's
been speculation that these four men
were going to steal something from the
scrap yard is that important to the case
or is it a red herring in a death and
dismemberment investigation
well it's not a red herring here's why
um if they're on bicycles that sort of
points in a direction of they weren't
trying to steal any scrap but there was
a witness that said that the four
General the gentlemen who were killed uh
they uh were up to no good uh so was
this self-defense on the part of Joe
Kennedy or was it something that he just
became angry because they were near his
yard and uh he just killed them we don't
know but uh Terry's right about the
civil suit uh freezing someone's assets
is always important for the victim
family and uh I understand he has a lot
of real estate holdings so he has a deep
pocket yeah I mean it's time to brush up
on the castle doctrine Oklahoma to see
how that plays out in this case well
coming up on lawn crime daily he's the
unpredictable defendant who's now a
convicted murderer many times over we're
breaking down some of the wildest
moments from the Daryl Brooks truck
plus one of the federal government's top
officials targeted the charges an
attacker now faces after Paul Pelosi the
husband of House of speaker